herbert economist Benjamin Friedman
makes the case that a country's moral
health runs parallel to its economic
strength his new book is the moral
consequences of economic growth and he
spoke about it recently at the American
Enterprise Institute in Washington DC
for about an hour 45 minutes my name is
Bob hahn and I direct something called
the AEI Brookings Joint Center for
regulatory studies and on behalf of
christum youth who has honored us by
being on the panel today who is
president of AEI and my distinguished
colleague at Brookings who I direct the
joint center with Bob lighten I'd like
to welcome you here I'd also like to say
thank you to Sasha gentling for putting
on such a wonderful show today and for
her continued support at the Joint
Center without it we wouldn't have near
the number of successful events that we
do seven years ago with Chris's help we
started a joint venture with the other
major think tank in town the brookings
institution whose aim was broadly
speaking to try to hold regulators and
elected officials more accountable for
some of the policies that they
promulgate both at the legislative level
and at the regulatory level we do that
in a number of ways including panel
discussions like today and we also have
a number of publications so for example
Sam peltzman who is from the University
of Chicago gave our distinguished
lecture recently on regulation and the
natural progress of opulence where he
talked about why regulation is not
likely to go away anytime soon which was
music to my ears because I I need a job
for the next decade net x decade the
preceding year we had Associate Justice
Breyer of the US Supreme Court deliver
an intriguing lecture which is also on
our website all our publications are
there on economic analysis and judicial
reason
me where he suggested there might be a
role for independent experts including
economists in informing judges decisions
on important technical matters such as
regulatory matters we've been honored in
terms of folks visiting our website for
downloads and for the first time last
month we actually had over a hundred
thousand downloads of our publications
both short and long you also if if
you're interested in signing up for our
newsletter which comes out about once a
month informing you about publications
and events like this should feel free to
fill out the blue card which each of you
has in your blue manila envelope your
blue envelope here and you can give it
to Sasha or one of our folks outside who
welcome to you coming into this
conference today's panel in its broadest
sense is about morality and economics
but as we shall see an understanding of
the relationship between morality and
economics I think could have some
important policy implications which
which is really what led me to dig in to
professors professor Friedman's book
morality and economics as you know from
your days in college our frequently
treated as separate subjects go on to a
university and try to find an economist
an economist ready to discuss the finer
points of content morality or a
philosophy professor who can discuss the
efficiency of price discrimination and
you're likely to get blank stares but
some notable economists and philosophers
have recognized that there is a linkage
including Adam Smith Lord Keynes and the
late john rawls to mention a few but at
least on the economic side there has
not been a great deal of discussion of
how economic growth one of the key
measures used to measure economic
progress is related to various aspects
of morality that is until professor Ben
Friedman penned this wonderful book
which he has told me that if you were
kind enough to purchase a copy he'd be
happy to autograph after this session
today the moral consequences of economic
growth as a result of this book I
predict that the study of morality and
economics could become a growth industry
unto itself perhaps solving some of the
externality problems that Professor
Friedman so presciently identifies in
his book since i'm not an expert on
morality I what Professor Friedman to
find that term but I'd like to spend a
minute or two on economic growth and if
you could turn your attention to the the
pie chart which sasha was kind enough to
prepare for me today if we think about
the economy just as a pie what is the
economic growth well one interpretation
of economic growth is simply that the
pie is expanding or getting larger over
time now you might say well gee that's
great that's one interpretation of
economic growth but what about my slice
well if you think of your slice is the
little green piece over there you're
probably most interested in whether your
slice is expanding or contracting over
time so we can have a notion that's you
know the economy as a whole is growing
or we might be interested in whether
certain segments of the economy are
growing so a majority of the population
is enjoying the fruits of economic
growth or perhaps only a few of us are
enjoying the fruits of economic growth a
key argument a professor Friedman's is
the generally speaking economic progress
and moral progress marched together and
economic decline
and stagnation are related to negative
moral consequences the thesis is nuanced
but that I think is the gist of it
professor Friedman makes an eloquent
case that individual liberty democracy
and morality tend to increase when
economies grow he goes on to success to
suggest that this is a cause-and-effect
relationship but it runs both ways so
it's complicated with growth leading
tomorrow progress and moral progress
leading to growth he also notes that
it's not true in all circumstances and
carefully diagnosis the US experience
during our major depression of the
century in the 1930s professor Friedman
suggests a number of ways in which the
US could improve its prospects for
economic growth in the future
particularly growth that could be
enjoyed by a broad majority of Americans
his wide-ranging suggestions include
changes in taxes Social Security
Medicare and education we're going to
ask professor Friedman to present his
work shortly but first I'd like to say a
few words about him and briefly
introduce our distinguished panel
Benjamin Friedman is the William Joseph
mayor professor of political economy and
formally chair of the department of
economics at Harvard University prior to
the moral consequences of economic
growth professor Friedman wrote days of
reckoning the consequences of American
economic policy under Reagan and after
which received the George S Eccles prize
given out by Columbia University he will
be joined today by the president of the
American Enterprise Institute christum
youth who I well I I will introduce
when the discussants speak and also
professor amitai etzioni of George
Washington University let me say a few
words about our ground rules for today's
discussion the first point is I'm going
to try to keep our distinguished
speakers to time with our first
presenter professor Friedman having 20
minutes to summarize a 4 or 500 page
book so that should be no problem for a
Harvard professor and then i'm going to
ask our discussants to keep their
remarks limited as well to somewhere in
the neighborhood of 12 minutes each
without any further ado I would like you
to welcome me in welcoming professor Ben
Friedman thank you thank you Bob for
your warm introduction and my thanks to
you and to Chris DeMuth and to Bob
lighten in absentia for inviting me here
today to discuss my new book with this
distinguished audience I've had over the
years a very positive relationship both
with Brookings and also with the
American Enterprise Institute and I've
been delighted to be associated with
both in various capacities and at
various times and so it's really a
pleasure to be here at this joint center
sponsored by the two institutions and
also to have an opportunity to discuss
with this wonderful audience the new
book that I've written the best way to
frame the discussion I believe is to ask
the question why should we care about
economic growth it almost sounds like a
silly question to ask most people's
reaction is of course we care about
economic growth but if we stop to
realize that we have so much difficulty
in our society in leading ourselves to
public policies that are genuinely
conducive of economic growth it
immediately becomes clear
our commitment to growth may not be
quite as solid or as strong as many of
us believe it would it is now the most
immediate thing to say is that if we
were among let us say two-thirds of the
world's citizens living in perhaps
three-fourths of the world's countries
the reason why we should be urgently in
favor of economic growth is almost
obvious for much of the world's
population increases in per capita
living standards translate very
immediately into improvements in the
most basic human dimensions of life with
higher incomes people live longer they
suffer from fewer diseases fewer of
their children died in infancy fewer of
their children and their fellow citizens
are malnourished but the truth of the
matter is that all of these improvements
in the basic human necessities have
pretty well played themselves out by the
time and economy or a society reaches a
per-capita income level somewhere
between a third and a half of what we
have in the United States so for example
the português portugal i pick because
it's the low end economically of the
euro 15 the Portuguese have a standard
of living approximately half what we
enjoy in the United States the
Portuguese live just as long as we do
the Portuguese suffer from no more
diseases than we do no more of their
children suffer infant mortality than
ours so there really isn't any
difference in these basic human
necessities similarly take one example
from Asia Korea by which I mean South
Korea has a standard of living not quite
forty percent what we enjoy in the
united states yet there it's true as
well koreans live as long as we do they
suffer from no more
or diseases than we do and their
standard of living in basic human terms
even though in economic terms is just as
healthy as ours in the United States the
argument that I suggest in the book is
rather different it is that when
societies are experiencing improving
material standards of living broadly
distributed across the great cross
section of the population that is the
circumstance under which a society is
also likely to experience improvements
in aspects of its social relations its
policies its legislation and its basic
social arrangements that Western
thinking ever since the Enlightenment of
the 18th century has construed
explicitly not just in moral terms but
explicitly positively in moral terms now
what are these moral positives that I
have in mind that I argue improve when a
society experiences improving material
living standards population one is the
provision of opportunity whether a
society provides opportunities to get
ahead for those who are able and willing
to take those opportunities or by
contrast as the society resist economic
and social mobility there is a
difference and there's no question but
that in Western thinking since the
Enlightenment we have regarded mobility
both economic and social as a moral
positive I have in mind secondly
tolerance tolerance with respect to what
well in America I suppose an immediate
answer would be race relations I have in
mind also religious prejudice I have in
mind in the United States attitudes
toward immigrants I argue in the book
also
in each of these dimensions as well when
the broad cross-section of the
population is experiencing improving
material standards of living the society
also becomes more tolerant less
prejudiced more willing to allow other
people to move forward thirdly I have in
mind some notion of fairness fairness is
of course difficult to define but I have
in mind fairness across groups and even
across individuals in an American
context we of course think of fairness
in the sense of equality of opportunity
but there is also the obligation not to
allow the disadvantaged among our
citizenry to fall too far behind the
accepted norms of the day providing
opportunities is one thing but the whole
point of having opportunities is
precisely that some people will be more
willing and more able to take advantage
of them than others and the question
then becomes what happens to the rest I
argue in the book as well that societies
become more prepared and more willing to
provide for the disadvantaged among them
when the material standard of living of
the broad cross-section of the
population is advancing and finally I
have in mind either the strength of a
society's demographic institutions
democratic institutions or the creation
of democratic institutions where none
existed before asked questions like who
gets to vote ask questions like whether
a country has a viable political
opposition is there a free press is
there a way for people who are
dissatisfied with existing political
parties to create new ones and do those
new parties have a prospect of entering
the political process here is well the
argument that I make in the book is that
in countries
like the United States where we already
have a well established democracy the
strength of our political institutions
is likely to become greater when the
majority of citizens are moving forward
in their living standards and conversely
when people have a sense of economic
stagnation or worse yet economic retreat
then the society not only makes no
further forward progress on democracy or
tolerance or fairness or provision of
opportunity and mobility but all too
often societies go into periods of
retrenchment often with quite disastrous
consequences now I'd like to frame
today's discussion by drawing out
explicitly for implications of this
hypothesis that I've suggested if it is
true first a very optimistic conclusion
if it is true that what matters for
purposes like opportunity and democracy
and tolerance and fairness is not just
how rich people are but also to a large
extent whether the bulk of the
population has a sense of moving forward
then countries throughout the developing
world where incomes are far below ours
in the United States should not have to
wait until they have achieved Western
income levels before they can and I
believe will experience significant
democratization to take just one example
consider again Korea most people are not
aware today that at the time of the
partition of North and South Korea a
half a century ago it was the South that
was considered the poor part of Korea
what we now call North Korea was the
industrial part of the country and
therefore was the richer part and what
we now call South Korea was the poor
agricultural part
all of which incidentally shows that it
is possible to make major league
mistakes in economics my point today
rather is that over a period of a
quarter century beginning in the early
1960s the Koreans underwent a quite
phenomenal period of economic
development in which per capita income
went from almost negligible by our
standards today to what I mentioned a
few moments ago a standard of living
that's approximately forty percent of
what we now have in the United States
and with some delay Korea transformed
itself from what had been a one-party
military dictatorship into what it is
today namely a functioning electoral
democracy with substantial political
freedoms of every recognized sort I
believe this is the pattern that many
countries throughout the developing
world will also now trace to take the
most obvious example that I assume is on
the minds of many people here today how
about China as most of us know the
Chinese have over the past quarter
century enjoyed the highest increase in
per capita living standards in the world
people who go to China which I do from
time to time see visibly just walking on
the street just looking at the houses
looking at the apartment buildings the
astonishing increase over this time in
people's material well-being yet China
remains at the federal level at least
anything but a democracy the strong
implication of the book and I would even
take it as a relevant test case would be
whether within our lifetimes China will
evolve in the direction of a liberal
democracy with a small ill and a small D
and I believe that if the Chinese are
able to continue their recent growth
performance indeed they will
if this conclusion sounds optimistic
that is because it is the hypothesis
that I put forward in the book and that
I've described today relating material
progress to moral progress is an
outgrowth of the kind of enlightenment
thinking that always drew its basic
substance from a profound optimism about
the human enterprise and i would like to
associate my ideas in this book quite
squarely with that kind of traditional
optimism the second implication that I'd
like to draw however is one that's more
sobering once again if it is true that
what matters for purposes of a society's
tolerance and democracy and fairness is
not merely how rich it is but also in
large part whether the bulk of the
population is moving forward then it is
a very sobering thought for Americans
today to remind ourselves that 2004 not
just last year for which we do not yet
have data but 2004 was the fifth
consecutive year in which the median
American income that is the income of
the person right at the middle of
America's income distribution failed to
keep pace with inflation now my book is
not about business cycles this is not
about comparing ourselves today versus
last year or the year before in the book
I continually picture people asking
themselves questions of a much more
long-term nature questions that depend
on the on the person station in the life
cycle really I picture young adults
asking themselves questions like how is
my career starting out compared to what
of all of my uncles and aunts knew in
their day a little further on in the
life cycle I picture people asking
what's it like living in my house
compared to what it was like in my
parents house a little further on how am
I providing for my children
compared to what I remember growing up
in my parents house a little further on
how is my career trajectory developing
compared to what my father knew and then
yet at a further stage what are the
prospects for my children going forward
compared to what I knew as a young man
or a young woman so these are questions
of an intergenerational character and
it's not about one year or two years or
even five years but five years is not a
trivial period either and we have every
reason to believe that when we learn in
the data for 19 for 2006 in 2005 we will
be continuing this pattern and as we go
forward the consequences are very
sobering now what kind of consequences
what kind of pathologies would a rich
country like the United States suffer if
it continues on in a mode in which even
though the total output is growing the
standard of living of the bulk of the
population is not in the book I asked
repeated series of questions of the
following form to take just one example
because I believe it would be on
everybody's minds because of the recent
unfortunate experiences in France in
particular how about attitudes toward
immigrants I asked the following series
of questions why did we have in the
United States all of the anti-immigrant
violence that we had in the 1850s why
did it then go away because it did go
away after the Civil War why did we then
have the returned in the 1880s and 1890s
not of violence but of really very ugly
anti-immigrant agitation and Prejudice
why did that then give away after the
turn of the 20th century to a movement
of welcoming immigrants and
Americanizing them many people are
unaware but in the early years of the
20th century the
fourth-of-july was called
Americanization day and then it became
very popular for many people to claim
usually falsely that they had been born
on the fourth of July for precisely this
reason this was also incidentally where
the American high school movement had
come from the United States had
pioneered Universal grammar school
education in the 19th century but as of
1900 only three percent of Americans had
graduated from high school but if we
were going to welcome immigrants in
large number and then Americanized them
there had to be some vehicle some
mechanism for making this happen and the
chosen mechanism of the day was
Universal high school education also
with what came to be known as a social
studies curriculum before 1900 nobody
had ever heard the word or the phrase
social studies to move the story forward
why did this welcoming attitude toward
immigrants didn't give way in the 1920s
to the most restrictive and the most
discriminatory immigration legislation
that the United States has ever seen in
our country's history these acts were
actually called the national origin acts
the idea was that if you came from
northwestern Europe that was okay if you
came from southern Europe say you're you
were from Italy or Greece or the Balkans
that was bad if you came from North
Eastern Europe say you were from Russia
or Poland that was very very bad and
then to move the story forward why were
those discriminatory acts completely
thrown out in the 1960s why then in the
latter part of the 1970s and on into the
1980s in the early 90s did we start to
get pushback on immigration things like
prop 187 in California movements in
Texas and Florida to deny various forms
of public benefits even to legal
immigrants
and why did all that disappear in the
1990s to such an extent that the one
candidate who chose to run for president
in the 2000 election on an explicit
anti-immigrant program namely Pat
Buchanan got so few votes in the
Republican primaries that he had to
change parties now it would be foolish
to pretend and I certainly do not that
every twist of the ups and downs of
immigration attitudes and policies in
the United States over a hundred fifty
year period has simply reflected the
underlying ebb and flow of the economics
but I argue in the book that it would be
even more foolish to pretend that it had
nothing to do with the economics and in
one dimension after another whether it's
immigrants whether it's religious
prejudice whether it's race relations
again the think about our democratic
institutions ask the questions when did
blacks get the vote when did women get
the vote when did blacks really get the
vote there was of course this small
matter of 95 years between the first
event and the and the other event each
of these I believe has a large amount to
do with the underlying economics and as
I say as we go into what may turn out to
be our seventh consecutive year of a
declining median standard of living in
the United States this is a sobering
prospect the third implication is one
that I believe I can state very quickly
for this audience in particular and that
is that the realization that economic
growth delivers such benefits as
democracy and fairness and tolerance and
mobility and opportunity means that the
right rate of economic growth is faster
than the rate of economic growth that
market mechanisms left to their own
devices would generate the argument is
somewhat similar to the
argument that we all understand whereby
market mechanisms left to their own
devices / provide things like pollution
and noise and congestion and there is
therefore a positive role for public
policy to step in and intervene in ways
that cut down on those noxious features
I argue in the book that realizing that
because we have no market where we buy
and sell democracy there is no price
placed on fairness there's no place
where you can go and buy an option on
tolerance means that similarly the
market mechanism left to its own will
under provide economic growth and there
is a positive role for public policy to
increase the economic growth rate beyond
where market mechanisms alone would take
it and as Bob mentioned I have quite a
few things to say in the book about what
such public policies might be the final
implication that I'd like to draw from
the hypothesis in the book is one that
is the most fundamental if it's true
that rising per-capita incomes broadly
distributed across the society lead to
these positive features like tolerance
and democracy and fairness and
opportunity then I believe we need to
change in a fairly fundamental way the
nature of our conversation in the public
arena about economic growth we have
fallen into a mode of talking about
growth in which we recognize of course
the material advantages of growth
everybody knows that but then against
those material advantages we balance
various drawbacks of the growth process
most obviously environmental degradation
but other drawbacks as well to which
over time we've come to attach a
oral connotation and as a result the
standard conversation about growth is
one of balancing material benefits
against moral costs and people come away
from this conversation with the sense
that their self image of themselves of
where do they place themselves on the
spectrum between do I care only about
material things or do I mostly emphasize
moral concerns their self-image in this
material versus moral spectrum is
somehow supposed to map into where they
should be on whether they should support
or resist economic growth and policies
for economic growth and a person who
says well I mostly care about material
things as well then of course I'm
supposed to be for growth and somebody
who says that no no I emphasize in my
life more moral concerns thinks
therefore i'm supposed to resist
economic growth the most fundamental
implication of the hypothesis I advance
in the book is that the notion of
evaluating growth by balancing entirely
material benefits against entirely moral
negatives is a false balancing and
therefore the mapping of that into one's
preferences about should I therefore be
for growth versus against growth is a
false mapping as well economic growth
brings with it I argue very important
moral benefits to repeat tolerance
opportunity mobility fairness and
democracy and if we could begin to alter
our public conversation about growth by
bringing those moral benefits into the
story then I believe over sometime we
will have a better process
effect of understanding why we should be
in favor of economic growth and
therefore of finding ourselves on the
road to public policies that will
genuinely promote economic growth thank
you very much discussing will be
christum youth who is president of the
American Enterprise Institute he's also
a leading intellectual and policy
entrepreneur chris has served as
publisher of regulation magazine as
director of regulatory studies at
Harvard's Kennedy School of Government
an executive director of the
Presidential Task Force on regulatory
relief in the Reagan administration we
thank Chris for taking time out of a
schedule today to participate in this
event this is a think-tank symposium not
a book fair and I'm required by the
stern conventions of the genre to engage
in cool analysis to section
qualification and criticism so first I
want to say that Ben Friedman has
written a magnificent book a great work
of synthesis an important contribution
to human knowledge the book is masterful
in combining historical and sociological
and literary and philosophical materials
with economics it is a terrific read
anybody who reads it is going to be
tremendously edified moreover and most
important i think that the essential
argument of the book the one that he has
emphasized here this morning that there
are a very great moral benefits to
economic growth is a great truth
now to work I want to focus on two
aspects of his book that I regard as
problematic and then I want to focus on
two aspects that I particularly like
that I think our particular strengths
and important features of his argument
my first criticism is this the book
shows that economic growth is closely
associated over long periods of time
with liberal enlightenment virtues which
he describes as open opportunity
tolerance economic and social mobility
democracy his thesis is that there is a
causal causal relationship from economic
growth to those political and moral
virtues it is that thesis that gives his
narrative its drive and interest and
momentum and he offers many intriguing
arguments for it especially the one he
summarized this morning that if an
individual's situation is improving
temporally it is getting better today
than it was in the past it looks like
it's going to be even better tomorrow
that one is more likely to see social
interaction as a positive sum game
rather than negative sum game one is
much more likely to welcome others along
for the ride but at other points in the
book professor Friedman describes the
reverse he mentions how at certain
periods openness and democracy and
tolerance a spirit of inquiry leads to
economic growth rather than the other
way around so in the end he is really
not profound in Freedman iron law of
moral growth but he is describing a
important and underappreciated tendency
he says at one point in the book that
cutting taxes will lead to increased
investment in capital formation and
welfare
if all other things are equal however
all other things are rarely equal I
think the same thing can be said for his
thesis it describes an important
tendency economic growth will lead to
political liberalization other things
being equal but I wish that he had
acknowledged that many of the examples
he gives in his historical narratives
are exceptions and I sometimes have the
feeling that I'm listening to a Voltaire
that I'm listening to this suite above
the fray a reason that abstract reason
that steers a little bit clear of a
narrative that is a much lumpier and
more problematical I want to give three
examples liberalisation and
democratization are not just a are not
just a matter of progressive social
attitudes they depend on a specific set
of institutions those institutions have
been enacted at specific points in time
usually the result of angry contention
strife and warfare liberal institutions
are for the most part responses to
specific and horrible abuses the Magna
Carta was not a volt arian document it
was a social revolution against the
specific abuses of a specific tyrant and
the insistence that steps be taken to
see that they not be recreated we often
think of the Declaration of Independence
as Voltaire ian is a liberal
Enlightenment document because it
crystallized in such a pithy in
beautiful form the Enlightenment spirit
in its famous central phrase but most of
the Declaration of Independence by far
the bulk of the text was simply a
recounting of the abuses of George the
third and a declaration to the world
a new set of institutions which the
individuals that signed it realized that
may have may require the sacrifice of
their lives in order to correct those
abuses liberal institutions in Japan and
in Germany were the result of their
being vanquished in wars and
institutions imposed upon them those
institutions late leading to changes in
political and social mores second
professor Friedman mentions the book
published just about a century ago by
Norman angel the great illusion which
argued roughly that economic prosperity
was leading to social progress and
arguments very much like that of Ben's
book the emphasis in social progress was
of course that increasing commercial
interactions and interdependencies would
lead to an end or in any event greatly
minimized the likelihood of warfare this
was written and became very popular for
years for the onset of the bloodiest
period in all of human history a period
which was both the richest century in
human history and the century that saw
the greatest illiberal slaughter of
human beings that has ever been seen it
is true that a great deal of that
slaughter by governments of their own
people took took place in very poor
places Russia and China but a great deal
of the slaughter of one's own citizens
took care took place in one of the
richest and most culturally advanced
nations on earth Germany and a good deal
of the slaughter was fights in two world
wars and many miner wars to follow and
we are now faced with a terror war where
the adversaries of liberal democracy are
precisely taking advantage of our very
openness and tolerance and technological
achievements to attempt to defeat us all
of these examples
just a competing thesis briefly that
human nature is durably two-sided
including great potential for good and
for progress and great potential for
evil and mayhem that economic growth and
prosperity and technological advance
amplify and accentuate both human
capacities both for good and for evil
and that that constitutes the central
moral dilemma of a highly prosperous
modern nation third economic growth
itself seems to breed a strong degree of
discontent not simply with its
byproducts such as pollution or global
inequality but specifically with with
commercial culture and commercial
institutions themselves there is in the
modern world a strong brand of radical
romantic environmentalism not the
pragmatic standard kind that most of us
share very strongly there is a breed of
anti-globalization which is not opposed
simply to international disparities or
in in income or the the benefits of
globalization but is simply approved
opposed to commerce pure and simple if
one did a demographic profile of the
radical environmentalists the radical
anti globalists or for that matter the
radical Islamic terrorists one would not
find people whose economic circumstance
was deteriorating but was getting much
stronger it seems that to some extent at
least among an important sub component
of modern society's prosperity leads to
radical disaffection my second criticism
is that when Ben comes to discussing the
modern era basically the last 25 to 30
years his personal politics in very
subtle but on most
a couple ways take apart take take come
to play a part in both the narrative and
the thesis I think that that's perfectly
natural fine and inevitable the present
is always much murkier and harder to see
than the distance distant past one's
political inclinations are how in an
important way one explains uncertainties
but i think that the book would have
been stronger if he had been more
explicit about this for one thing i
think that it is pushing his thesis a
little too hard that is that economic
growth produces openness tolerance more
democracy and so forth to try to
calibrate things so finally as that in
the 1980s we had bad economic policies
we had stagnation and social unrest and
a growth of intolerance and then in the
1990s we had sound policies and economic
rebound and a welcome return of
tolerance and enlightenment and since
2001 a return of the dark old days the
thesis is not capable of calibrating
things so so finally but most important
i think that the stakes that we have in
increased openness tolerance and
democracy today are more interesting
complicated and contestable than his
discussions suggest I regard myself for
example as a supremely open and tolerant
person very deeply engaged on the
subject of racial justice and progress
and yet I am opposed to most forms of
affirmative action in their strong form
of racial quotas specifically because
they're racially discriminatory and I
think social poison I was part of the
welfare reform debates of the 80s and
early 90s a professor Friedman says that
that debate often displayed
vindictive spirit I'm sure that there
was in some case but the story of
welfare reform i believe is better told
as a story of a convergence of liberal
and conservative views on the effects of
especially AFDC in in destroying lives
and hurting people and an honest effort
to try to come to grips grips with that
hate groups and anti-government militias
are now he says returning to the
periphery I think that they have been at
the periphery for a very very long time
and I do not worry that they are going
to return to America if we grow in the
future less fast and in the past Adam
Smith in the 18th century had specific
ideas when he talked about openness
tolerance and progress john stuart mill
in the 19th century had specific ideas
about individual rights tolerance and
openness what are the stakes that we
have in more openness more tolerance
more democracy today I myself would say
that today's American society is the
most open and tolerant society in the
history of humankind I can't see any
calibrations in the last 20 years of
more or less tolerance but most
important and this is my key point
economic growth is an open-ended
continuous process openness tolerance
and democracy are not there's nothing
you liberal to say that there are some
things that a society ought not to
tolerate that there are some things that
we ought not to be open about that there
are some limits and some room for
balancing some place I think that Ben's
discussion of immigration is
particularly particularly good but I
think that having propounded such a
profound thesis describing what it is
specifically that continued economic
growth would provide two Americans
beyond a guarantee that we wouldn't
slip back to the days of racial
prejudice or whatever would be something
that if I'd been reading the manuscript
of this I would have pressed him very
hard to tell us more about that now I
want to tell you the two things I like a
whole lot about this book second first
of all putting economic growth at the
very center of government policy making
there's lots of room in the America the
Western world's the Western societies
for disagreement on the specifics of
what it is that will lead to the highest
rate of economic growth in the future
but simply saying that that is our goal
and what we should be arguing about is
how to achieve that goal and debunking
some of the casual anti-growth arguments
that are often stated in moral terms is
the most important contribution of this
this very fine book I agree
wholeheartedly that there is a
tremendous disorder in our economic
policies in America and in Western
Europe that a day of reckoning is coming
fast especially on the course of
entitlement spending as we face a great
demographic shift and that the
disconnect between the real problems we
face and the policy priorities of both
of our major political parties is a
subject of a great concern and I hope
that everybody takes his ideas to heart
I myself am for higher rates of economic
growth even if they lead to less
immediate happiness I agree that we're
saving too little and spending too much
and it may make us happy to be spending
our grandchildren's inheritance I'm
really not sure if we will become
happier or less happy if we do the right
thing by them our major form of domestic
investment seems to be purchasing a
larger more spacious and more housing as
opposed to investing in productive
enterprise that's a policy driven a
choice I would like
see it changed I'm not sure which way
the short-term economic tolerance and
openness results would be but I'm for
doing it anyway his lesson is
particularly important in the developing
world there i think the mystery that the
western world having perfected the
institutions of growth in our own
nations seemed to have been completely
unable to help poor nations to get on
with the task of development is a great
and very worrisome mystery but what has
been for decades a set of policies that
were essentially in my view anyway guilt
money on behalf of the rich nations or
walking around money for secretaries of
state and foreign ministers has now
become an area of very very serious
policy as a result of globalization as a
result of the war the growth as a result
of the terror war we now have to get
serious about economic development
policy its purpose has to really be to
produce results in terms of the economic
growth of the poor part of the world and
Ben's discussion is a great clarion call
there finally in briefly i particularly
like his discussions of school reform
and medical care reform both because i
agree that education and medical care
are by far the two biggest domestic
policy challenges that we are facing
ought to be given top priority and i
like very much not only his emphasis on
the introduction of market incentives
competition and choice things that i
like very much but even more that more
than that i like the way he
characterizes those reforms and advances
them in the past decade as choice and
competition have pretty much been the
province of conservative and libertarian
reformers the emphasis has been far far
too much on individual choice and I
believe that one of the reasons the
reform proposals have not advanced
further is that too many Americans
talking about something this that they
regard is import socially important as
public education the idea that the
central criterion should be individual
choice rings a little bit hollow and
strange what Ben Friedman says is that
the reason we want competition and
choice is not just to give individuals
more choice but but to produce a far
more effective and productive medical
care suck sector and education sector in
emphasizing public good rather than
private choice in the introduction of
market reforms I think that he has
offered a very important way out of the
liberal-conservative impasse on medical
care and school reform thank
amitai etzioni is university professor
at George Washington University he has
served as a senior economic advisor to
the White House as chairman of Columbia
University sociology department and his
president of the American Sociological
Association professor Etzioni is is well
equipped as anyone that I know to
discuss the moral implications of
economic policy he is the author of the
influential book the moral dimension
towards a new economics and is the
founder of the communitarian Network a
not-for-profit nonpartisan organization
dedicated to shoring up the moral social
and political foundations of society a
task that is well above my pay grade and
with that I welcome the comments of
Professor Etzioni thank you very much I
would be delighted to have a degree in
economics but all I was a senior adviser
but I this is it has already been
pointed out and extremely rich book I
much would prefer to have a six month
seminar on it then commented for 12
minutes and that wouldn't quite do I
mean it really I urge you all to reach
it and he didn't see a hard brings
together enormous about is of knowledge
from a very large varieties of
disciplines which make it simply a
fascinating read aside from an enriching
one now the place i would start as
somebody who's at least trained in
sociology is to ask what happened to Max
Weber Max Weber had the thesis that
values drive both economic development
and the specific more policies at the
vigil a professor Friedman
so clearly alludes I mean to put in a
little more technical language
sociologists worry about what they
called spurious correlations that when
you see two things go together like
high-rise buildings and high crime rates
it's not that the high crime rates cause
high buildings or high buildings across
high crime rates something else behind
him driving both that's of course while
vapor compared Protestants to what in
those days like the Catholics of those
days which were very intolerant of many
of the things professor Friedman talks
about and in those days it was a
question if Catholicism could be made
compatible with capitalism or democracy
the same question now people ask about
Islam in fact vapor event also to study
Islam in China and the underlying
hypothesis is that value changes drive
both economic development and specific
liberal more democratic institution I'm
not saying that's the answer I'm just
saying something in that seminar of six
months I'd like to have one session
dedicated to that question the next
session is going to be still stay with
this very language of variables if you
listened carefully you heard an
interesting change of conversation
sometimes the deriving variable was
characterized as economic growth and by
distribution of the benefits and
sometimes reference was made to search
by Chris to only economic growth that
makes a world of difference because as
we know all too well in China India and
you professor Friedman referred United
States you can get very rapid economic
growth without necessarily much
distribution or even with less
distribution and the question then is
what is the driving factor here what if
you get a lot of economic growth and
nobody's tribution or what you get out
of our distribution butter a little
economic growth do the same public
policies which promote one necessarily
promote the other now I think that's the
second session I'd like to have
discussing
how to disaggregate these two variables
and how they relate to one another now
to be a little accurate here it's almost
impossible to have very rapid economic
growth is that anything spilling over to
the master it's not a question if
there's some distribution but the
question is can you have all those
liberalization policies all those quote
more things if you do not have by
distribution the kind of thing we see
but revolves was not troubled by that
all the idea was as as long as when you
put up the top classes the lowest class
also get something he was happy I'm not
sure professor Friedman would completely
accepted this idea of this great wealth
for liberal one of the most telling
sentences in the book is on page 80 the
professor friedman for one sentence
become a card-carrying communitarian
where he argues that what really matters
is family and friendships and I would
saw in community we talked about this
point what are the correlates of
happiness if you have good friends and
have a strong family and I would add a
strong community a lot of data a lot of
data shows you're going to be much more
content than otherwise but do these
factors strong friendship strong family
and strong communities correlate
positively with economic growth not
necessarily not shown in this book so
the third session of the my six-month
seminar or maybe three and four and five
going to the crashing is their attention
between strong human bonding and rapid
strong economic growth um let me add to
that Professor Friedman does provide
that's one of the greatest things of the
books enormous bodies of data and
therefore would be really almost
uncalled for to ask about some other
bodies of data is so that if you can
play a game is any book say you know
about but there is a sizable body of
data which shows there's no college
between happiness and economic growth
beyond a certain level then they cannot
economy in Japan and the period economic
Japan the gdp grew four times the
percentage of Japanese increased who
were more content before was increasing
sleeper sent the famous the Michigan
area studies show that as a United
States economic goals increased the
distribution of happiness did not
increase it bubbling and our kind of
large number of studies so I'm not
completely convinced yet that economic
growth drives contentment you profound
human content in but I am convinced and
I think there is on that enough data to
shake the stick ethic to convince the
southern jury that the strong human
relationships are an important source of
human contentment and arguably at least
they are disrupted by a rapid economic
growth now the one which really gets me
going is when economists return to
psychology that you know it this is the
death I am NOT professor Friedman but in
some other works they favor dummy
variables when the equation doesn't add
up you didn't stick in psychology so if
two plus two makes six you talk about
psychic income you see and this disciple
cycling income is determined by what
you're missing to make sure the equation
to equal out I'm very seriously if you
ask why people do things when there is
no higher pay or no other material
rewards this always this magic comes in
it is attributed to psychic income now
as I could very psychological variables
play very interesting war in this book
because it's not simply economic growth
or distribution of the benefits which
are the driving story is what people
expect which is a little closer to my
base to
my study of sociology social psychology
then to econometrics and that's a very
key subject the suggestion in the book
is that basically the suggestion that's
not a place where the Zen is data that
what basically drives people's
expectations is how to compare
themselves to their past and how to
compare themselves to people around them
but that's a very problematic area
because we call that reference groups I
mean whom you're compared is too and
it's not at all evident that this is
unnecessarily the most important groups
some people compare himself to water see
on television one of the problems is
when we start to show worldwide
addiction famous and the lifestyle that
bet becomes something people compared
himself to people confound himself for
the firefighters in your compare
themselves to the police neither days it
insisted the sudden veggie differential
they remained whatever the actual age
reference groups are subject to a
education in a manipulation maybe the
most telling study here which really
says it all is one of the first that is
done of reference group actually I think
the first one it based on the American
soldier data they're finding visual work
at least among my colleagues is still
considered a very very startling one and
that is they compared in the United
States Army the military police to the
Air Force Anna military police
promotions were extremely difficult to
get the and yet to vet many years to get
one in the Air Force they were very
common and the assumption was there for
that people in the Air Force would be
much more content than in the military
police in terms of was exactly the
opposite and so when packing nobody got
it you were delighted and surprised when
you got it if everybody got it alone you
were not one of them I didn't get as
much the other it created a kind of
spiraling
of expectations the parallel would be
here is not surprising people in
Portugal and some some other countries
like this are content they are the
military police they don't have such
high expectations and I would not
surprised if people in China and in
India will become much more discontent
as they see a pic rising so what drives
psychology what drives expectations what
are the powerful reference group how
they are changed is a subject for all
other seminar now on page 92 it is
suggested that economic growth drives
expectations and that kind of winner
gets a whole other story if that is the
case you know you really have to start
from the beginning our expectation and
independent factor and if yes what
drives them how to develop economic
goals i think is part of the discussion
here but let me get off this social
sciences stuff and talk about more than
moral side of things the question is in
the end I granted that mall economic
growth if widely distributed correlates
as many of the things professor friedman
celebrates and i do shorthand called
liberal here the question is when is
enough enough nobody i think in his
right mind wanders only to dedicate
herself to economic growth but what if
we are sleeping 2 / 2 24 7 society and
in the process sacrificing ever more
other things to economic growth which in
return does not pay off in terms of the
spiritual and social and cultural values
of our life and that's really a crucial
point so let me for a moment put in some
data I know I'm going to get in trouble
here but you know it's my only chance
the whole thing reminds me sometimes of
those of you seen the movie 80 days
around the world he kept hang on the
train to feed the dystocia he keep going
in and then there's nothing left you
notice the income per capita has not
increased nearly as much as being
compared household why because I'll take
as much everybody outside sudden of the
minute-long guy show but I tell you what
is going to help me like in my glass of
water
what happened here how can the income
per household grow significant modern
income per capita because women who used
to work in the household bizarre the
explicit compensation largely moved
outside the household so now you have
often one point seven people working in
a household and therefore even if there
is no significant income per capita you
can have a significant income spare
household but now that they are working
partly there's the future God's going to
come from an Italian answer is going to
come from pure holidays longer hours
employing teenagers employing elderly if
you go and look at our juniors and
seniors you see the twenty thirty forty
percent of them work up to 20 and 30
hours a week at mcdonalds and and
Marriott in such flipping hamburgers and
adding to the family income and if you
go to Florida you see more more senior
citizens forced to work they're not
appendicitis tix because many of them
work off the books in order to keep the
kind of an income they need that is a
society in which people bring proof
cases and work home or work two jobs
which shows you the direction you go
when there is no ceiling on when you not
I'm not talking about the pool I'm not
talking about in the middle class but if
there is no sense that is somewhere is
enough enough let me put it in a
different language if there's no other
cognition that income has a declining
marginal utility maybe that's language
to recognize then we going to lead in a
world in which there's a race to the
bottom and I think the answer is in
recognizing that there yeah is a lot of
very own economic goals for its own sake
because it shows off all the things we
heard about but we should not neglect
the effect it undermines some also some
core values and therefore the notion we
have to find some kind of
sunbird or the line that we have to say
something you're not going to sacrifice
to become more efficient is part of the
conversation of the moral consequences
of God and let me close here by saying
if you if you be only concerned with
distribution if you only concerned the
sort of justice it's the only concern is
a location the same story arises under
what conditions are people willing to
significantly allocate only when they
have a strong belief in something other
than economic growth I have all this
upper middle class kids in my school and
such and they all know social troll many
of them are liberals and so I love to
interview them and said where you get
that sense you know I mean you are well
off your parents aware of why you get up
every morning and bleed about the poor
you know I mean they're very cups from
and by the way turnt it's not always
obvious to them at least but if you
interview them long enough it comes from
religious values from the National of
the charity and such which they got some
how often not though I did not even know
I've often very guarded form but look at
the people who are willing to trade the
other way some income some efficiency is
either because they believe like the
voluntary simplicity because the
environmentalist because a day most
important absorb the social gospel so I
don't think this story is complete and
by the way professor free maturity isn't
not inattentive to it that we need to
ask given granted that economic growth
has positive more consequences also how
and when we are going to balance it for
other human commitment and values
professor Friedman would you like to
respond before we open things up thanks
Bob first and most importantly let me
thank both Chris and Emmett I for very
very thoughtful incisive and we'll
articulated sets of substantive
reactions for which I'm very grateful
and I want to thank Chris in particular
for his likening my writing to that of
Voltaire that is easily the nicest thing
that anyone has had to say about me for
a very long time my wife excepted of
course now there were several themes
that were in common in Chris's comments
and amma ties and so i'd like to take a
minute or two to address those before we
open the discussion to see what others
in the group have to say several of
these i can take care of i believe
fairly quickly not that they're quick
subjects but simply to sketch out the
point of view that I articulate in the
book first both Chris and amitai in
effect asks the question what is the
direction of causation is the idea that
economic growth is the cause of openness
and mobility and tolerance and fairness
and democracy or is it rather that those
features of a society enable that
society's economy to achieve better
economic growth and the answer I believe
is both and in the book I have something
to say about the ways
which a more open and democratic society
is on that account better able to
achieve economic growth but the
predominant force of the book is after
all as the title indicates the
consequences of economic growth so I
have no either interest in or desire to
resist the notion that the causation
goes both ways and indeed I believe it
does but it is true that the focus in
this book is on growth as the driving
factor second Chris asked the question
what else is being held constant and
indeed can we held enough things
constant this is another way of asking
what are the limiting conditions for
this hypothesis after all this is not
physics this is social science and one
thing that we know is that there are no
such thing as universal hypotheses in
the social sciences so a way to frame a
part of Chris's discussion is to ask
what are the limiting conditions and I
must say that in this book I shied away
from I have my ideas on that subject but
in this book I quite deliberately shied
away from the notion of exploring the
limiting conditions my sense of
intellectual strategy is that if one is
dealing with a large idea in the social
sciences and I think this is a large
idea the right economic strategy is to
paint that idea as broadly as possible
and then to let the ensuing discussion
as Chris Illustrated start to delineate
the limits on on the on how the idea
applies and it would certainly not be
true that in all places and on in all
circumstances the hypothesis in the book
is right the
one exception of which I make rather a
big deal in the book is the Great
Depression experience in the United
States but surely there are limiting
conditions that could be more generally
stated and as a deliberate matter of
intellectual strategy I did not do that
amitai raised the question of whether
the driving force in my conception of
how all this works is growth or growth
with distribution and the answer here is
very straightforward its growth with
distribution that the mechanism in my
story is a mechanism that Springs from
the sense of progress or lack thereof
enjoyed by the broad cross-section of
the population this is not a story about
what's happening at the very top of the
income distribution this is not a story
about what's happening at the very
bottom of the income distribution to to
echo senator Ben Stein's comment from
many years ago it turns out that I knew
Jack rolls I like Jack rolls I am no
Jack rolls this is not a story about the
very bottom of the distribution think in
terms of maybe the middle three fifths
of the income distribution that's the
driving force in my story and that's why
I'm concerned about the most recent
half-dozen years in the United States
after all if we were not interested in
the distribution then the plane story is
that over these last half-dozen years
the GDP in the United States has on
average outpaced inflation by a little
more than three percent that's doing
awfully well but the point is that the
median citizen hasn't enjoyed it now two
more issues that I can deal with briefly
and then I'll stop and that does a
disservice to many of the fine and
interesting points that both Chris and
amitai
raised but I do want to be able to hear
from everyone here amitai raised the
scary to me as well prospect that the
economic growth could come from simply
more people working ever more hours so
that the labor force participation Rises
the work week Rises and therefore more
and more of one's human hours are
devoted to the formal work this is
certainly not what I have in mind this
is not what Adam Smith had in mind in
the ideas that I keep coming back to in
the book it's worth pointing out that
over the last 200 years the average
growth rate in the United States has
been about one point eight percent per
annum beyond inflation that's very very
good for any economy to keep up for 200
years but it's also worth remembering
that that average growth rate over such
a long period took place in an era of a
declining workweek people did not simply
work more hours the answer to where does
the economic growth rate come from has
to be an improving productivity growth
and that's why the two aspects of the
growth process that I emphasized in the
policy recommendations of the book are
one let's increase the rate and the
quality of the human capital that we are
creating and second let's increase the
rate and the quality of the physical
capital that we're creating why in both
cases to make us a more productive
society so that we can have increases in
the standard of living without simply
having it people put in more hours on
the job the final point that I would
like to make is not a rebuttal but
rather an agreement I think amitai said
something very important at the very end
of his come in in which he talked about
not just the role of values which is
where
Mathai started but in particular the
role of religious values and in a number
of key points in the book I emphasized
the role of religious values in
influencing economic thinking both in
the sense of thinking by economists but
also in the sense of thinking by the
citizenry at large about economic
matters an example of the latter is of
course baber as Emmett I mentioned but I
have an argument in the book as well
that even Adam Smith I say even Adam
Smith because we know historically the
Smith was not a religious man I argue in
the book that even Adam Smith was
heavily influenced in some of his
thinking by changes in religious
theology at the time so I think the
point that amitai makes that religious
values are an important part of the
story is very much worth emphasizing I
agree with it very much and I think he's
quite on target in mentioning it Bob
there are other things I could say but I
suggest that I not and I suggest let's
hear from everybody else sounds great
the floor is open for questions if you
could direct them to a specific person
that would be great and if you could be
brief that would be even greater and
wait for the microphone if you would and
please identify yourself
I
um good afternoon for professor Friedman
and also for mr. muth department oh I'm
sorry Alliance for jura I'm from DHS I'm
a economic auditor if you will the
proponent of economic growth and the
redistribute ership of economic growth
is the government are rather very large
inefficient if you're it's inefficient
even by Democrat Big L Big D Democrat
standards how do you make it more
efficient for pro-growth and for
economic redistribution I'll give you
only one example from among the quite a
few that i have in the book that is a
matter of government policy and that has
to do with our rate of human capital
formation we know alas that there are
many children in the United States who
arrive at school unable to learn and
every day go home from school to home
environments one almost hesitates to
call some of them home environments in
which learning is difficult if not
impossible a truly shocking relationship
is that fifty percent of the cross
student variation in eighth grade
mathematics performance I take that one
because eighth grade mathematics
performance then on the other side is
closely related to how people do in the
job market later on in life fifty
percent of the Cross student variation
in eighth grade mathematics performance
is predictable on the basis of
characteristics of the student that the
teacher can write down on the first day
that the child walks into kindergarten
this is really quite shocking so we also
have a lot of evidence now accumulating
that early intervention programs project
head start among
others are effective not in permanently
raising test scores but in determining
such outcomes as among these at-risk
children which ones are going to finish
high school which ones are going to get
in trouble with the law which of the
girls are going to get pregnant as
teenagers which ones are going to go on
to college which ones are going to be
able to hold jobs in later years an
example of a policy which both increases
our economic growth rate and makes the
distribution of opportunity in our
society fairer would be to pursue
programs again the evidence is the
earlier the intervention the more
effective the program for sue programs
aimed at equalizing the opportunity in
our society I'll give you just one
further example and then see what Chris
has to say I emphasize early
intervention but how about later on how
about in college Jim heckman economist
at the university of chicago estimates
that only eight percent of american
youngsters ought to be going to college
but are prevented from doing so by
financial constraints now Jim is
comparing the eight percent who can't go
but should to the benchmark of a hundred
percent but from the perspective of
economic growth in productivity and the
role of Education in promoting growth
the important benchmark is not the
hundred percent but the fact that the
college completion rate in America is
only twenty-eight percent so compared to
a society in which twenty-eight percent
of American young people finish
four-year degrees hekman is finding that
another eight percent ought to be going
are qualified to go but can't go because
of financial constraints represents
another set of opportunities both to
increase the growth rate
the economy and simultaneously to create
a fairer distribution of opportunity in
society so I think even within the realm
of government and of course remember I
teach at a private institution in which
private philanthropy is very much a part
of providing the opportunity but even
within the realm of government that your
question emphasizes I think we know
plenty of policies that would be
available that would simultaneously
increase the potential growth and also
make for a fairer distribution of
opportunities I'm Mike McManus I my wife
I run an organization called marriage
savers whose goal is reduced the divorce
rate raised the Mara trade we had a
tragedy at 911 with 3,000 lives of that
act of terror but we've had four million
divorces since nine eleven oh one we've
had six million children born out of
wedlock it would seem to me that if
we're interested in trying to change the
percentage of people who are whose
incomes are rising we need to change the
marriage divorce and non marriage factor
the marriage rate has fallen forty-eight
percent since 1970 I've heard you say
anything about this institution and
wonder what you would like to add to
what you've said you're quite your
observation is quite right and I say
right up front in the book that morality
can be defined in many many ways and
some people interpret morality in terms
of marital or sexual behavior and some
people interpret morality as a matter of
using or abusing various substances and
some people interpret morality in terms
of telling the truth to one's co-workers
that without in any way saying that
those are not important because to be
sure those things are important that is
simply not what this book is about this
book is about
morality in the 18th century sense that
Smith and others use the term the book
is about the morality of the society and
that's why my both in the book and in my
remarks today I've been emphasizing the
the aspects of economic growth that bear
on characteristics of the society as a
whole again like tolerance and
opportunity and mobility and democracy
but that is not for one minute to
suggest that I believe or anybody should
believe that matters of personal
morality are also important and it's not
for a minute to suggest that those
matters of personal morality might not
be related to economic activity perhaps
in a way that bears some relation to the
book that I wrote on social morality
incidentally just to make your point
somewhat stronger amitai correctly
pointed to evidence that shows and I
talked about this evidence in the book
as well that shows that in most Western
societies the principal determinants of
how happy people are are not how rich
they are but things having to do with
personal relationships and in most
studies foremost among those personal
relationships is precisely the one that
you mentioned the variable that's almost
old not always but almost always at the
top of the list in any statistical study
is whether people are married and I
should say that when this this this is
one of the few examples that I find in
my teaching in which one can actually
appeal to the concept of authority when
I teach this to harvard college
undergraduates it is typically the case
that I'm the only married person in the
room and so I and I invoke the notion of
personal authority
to say yes this happens to be true
dr. Friedman could you correct me if i'm
wrong or better yet elaborate with
examples you said economic forces left
to their own devices won't lead to as
much growth as if aided to have that
right I'm sorry say that once again
please I want to make sure I got the
question right uh market mechanisms left
to their own devices will under provide
economic growth yes under provide
compared to what I argue the growth rate
should be that if we simply leave the
market mechanism to its own devices then
all of the families will decide how much
they want to save and all of the firms
will decide how much they want to invest
and through this wonderful process that
we take great delight in explaining to
introductory economics students every
year that will determine a rate of
economic growth that's the market
determined rate of growth then the
question is whether as a matter of
preference we should want the market we
should want the actual rate of economic
growth to be slower than or equal to or
faster than that rate of growth that the
families deciding how much to save and
the firm's deciding how much to invest
would deliver and an implication of my
hypothesis is that we should want an
economic growth rate that would be
faster than what this purely
market-determined rate would be and
therefore we should seek economic
policies that would spur the economic
growth rate to be faster that's the
argument
had a purely market determine economic
growth rate now well probably in the
United States in the United States never
but rather than just making a trivial
statement let me say I very much agree
with what I think to be the unstated
premise behind your question I think
what you're really saying is don't we
actually have government policies that
instead of spurring the growth rate to
be faster actually [ __ ] the growth
rates so that it's probably slower then
the market determined growth rate would
be and I think in with respect to many
of our policies the absolute answer is
yes we do and so what I would like to
see is fewer policies that [ __ ] the
growth rate and more policies that
enhance the growth rate as amat i said
before growth isn't isn't everything and
therefore there are some policies that
are eminently worth having even if they
do [ __ ] economic growth we all know
that but on balance I would much prefer
compared to our current situation in the
United States I would much prefer to
have fewer policies that [ __ ] the
growth rate and more policies that spur
the growth ring last question Jesse over
there just
vast and Mallory from the Washington
Post it seems to me that your
intellectual strategy and by the way I'm
very pleased to see is are not only
newspaper columnist that have
intellectual strategies of simplifying
and overstating it seems to be
professors as well that's a nice thing
for me to hear but it seems that your
strategy is and to sort of concede the
happiness literature thesis that above a
certain level of GNP per capita you
don't see growth and happiness in these
sociologist surveys and then say well
because we don't see individuals getting
happier with more growth we turn now to
this political morality argument that
that's where the real payoff from growth
will come and I'm just wondering whether
and given that there are some comebacks
on the political morality claims those
amitai and Kristen Wiig were saying and
whether in fact you could have fought a
bit harder in the case for growth on the
personal side of me after all even if
people aren't telling surveyors that
they're happier doubling their incomes
allows them to buy things that they
presumably do actually want and it could
be not necessarily that they live longer
but maybe they travel more they get to
go and see their cousin who's gone to
move to from Portugal to Germany or
whatever it is I mean there must be some
utility in the other half of the income
even if it doesn't get picked up in
these servers so i guess the quickly
simplified the question is are you
really persuaded by this finding that
happiness does not increase for
individuals oak I've a certain level
well first place let let me begin by
resisting the notion that having a sense
of intellectual strategy is identical to
simplification an overstatement I think
I think that I think your your self
effacing introduction notwithstanding I
think that's no more characteristic of
the academic part of the professional
intellectual endeavor than it is to the
journalistic part and neither you nor
your newspaper do that and I'd like to
think that I don't either now let me be
more specific on what the surveys do and
do not show we have an overwhelming
amount of evidence that what matters for
people's happiness or satisfaction to
use the psychological phrase is not
people's absolute level of income or
standard of living but rather their
standard of living compared to some
benchmark in other words what matters is
standard of living relative to something
else so as it isn't that the finding
isn't the living standard doesn't matter
it matters very much it doesn't matter
absolutely it matters in a relative
sense now the crucial question for
purposes of my work is what is it that
it's relevant a relative to that matters
and I emphasize in my work to relative
benchmarks for standard of living both
of which i think are well supported in
these surveys one how are people doing
compared to how they've done in the past
we do have evidence that this matters
second how are people doing compared to
other people and this is exactly what
sets the stage for the question amitai
ask about who which other people matter
is it just among the neighbors on my
block is it everybody at my university
is it the entire city of Boston is the
whole country who matters these are
important issues that I'm not going to
solve here
the crucial thing to realize though is
that once we recognize that both of
these benchmarks are relevant then
something very important emerges and
this is really at the heart of the line
of analysis that I'm pushing suppose you
lived in Garrison Keillor's Lake Wobegon
everybody is doing better than everybody
else in that case because people are
deriving so much satisfaction from doing
so much better than everybody else the
urgency that people attached to doing
better than they personally or their
families have done in the past is
reduced well admiration for mr. Keeler
notwithstanding we're not going to have
that world because we can't by contrast
imagine a world in which everybody has
the sense of doing better compared to
what he or she or the person's family
has done in the past that's my
definition of economic growth in that
circumstance because people are doing
better on one benchmark again they feel
less urgency associated with doing
better on the other benchmark which
means that they are more prepared to as
either Chris or Emmett I put it I can't
remember which let other people come
along for the ride i think that was
Chris's phrase and this is the crucial
this is the crucial step in the argument
and I would say it's very consistent
with this evidence that shows that
living standard or income per se doesn't
matter living standard or income
relative to either or both of these
other benchmarks is very much a part of
the story
well I think our discussants made it
clear that at least agree that there is
an important connection between morality
and economics even though if it's not
the precise connection drawn in this
book and that it's also true that
Professor Friedman has illuminated a
very important insight in his book and I
would commend it to all of you and I'd
like you to join me in thanking our
discussants as well as our featured
speaker Benjamin Friedman is a political
economy professor at Harvard University
the moral consequences of economic
growth is published by konov visit a a
Knopf com for more information